on this episode tom bill you stops by
and we talk impact [ __ ]
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 299 of the ask gary vee
show which before I introduced Tom and
get into the Q&A Facebook and Instagram
I know you're watching Instagram if you
want to get a question and you got to go
to Facebook I liked it cool so we're
going to Instagram Facebook if you're
watching if you want to ask a question
to Tom who's an incredible entrepreneur
who's an incredible new member of the
Vayner family for a second time we're
gonna get into that we're gonna announce
a little fun stuff maybe a little
preview if you want your question what
are you worried about mcc's he wants a
closer that's right what are you doing
with your computer otherwise yeah cool
that's fine um Gary Vee team at
vaynermedia comm put in your put your
question in the subject email and your
phone number in the body if you want to
ask Tom a question during the show
Facebook and Instagram
it's Gary Vee team at vaynermedia comm
put your question in the title and your
phone number in the body we're gonna ask
a question a minute this episode two
ninety nine which means hey we need a
real strategy for episode 300 be I'm
super pumped you're here dude I'm
psyched to be here man tell the
vaynernation who you are my name is Tom
bill you I'm one of the cofounders of
quest nutrition and now I'm doing impact
Theory came up as an entrepreneur
because I was super frustrated with my
inability to get a movie made the way
that I wanted to and I met these two
successful entrepreneurs and I said look
dude if you want to control the
you got to control the resources so come
with us and get rich and we all thought
it would take about 18 months I thought
this is amazing it took 15 years how are
you at the time like 25 26 to go - right
before I let you continue like this is
my whole damn thesis of like lack of
impatience and like not contextualizing
time when you're 25 18 months seems like
a long time we can put a lot of work
yeah it's so true and now in your 40s 15
years doesn't seem so long it's here on
Tex of time yeah for sure it's really
cool okay so what were you guys gonna
first do it started in technology yeah
and chase that it was literally chasing
money that was it my sole folks I woke
up every day saying I'm going to get
rich it was the like centralized and
when you do you think that's precisely
when I change that thesis so doing that
I actually did on paper was a
multi-millionaire but I had so burnt out
I went and quit and I gave the equity
back I said look I'm not what are you
worth you know more than seven figures
right or seven figures just like a lot
of people running around now who are
rich on paper but when the economy
collapses if that company goes out of
business they're gonna be at zero yeah
people do not understand the difference
between real money and paper money man
it's crazy how this is why I keep
putting out the content and putting out
I'm like cool I'm glad that you work at
this startup that's now worth a billion
and you're worth eleven million on paper
but until the exit you're worth zero
zero and when the economy collapses and
there's no fundraising round and you're
direct-to-consumer gigolo company
doesn't make any doesn't can't raise
more capital then it goes for zero yeah
like every one of these kids have to
learn about the crash of 2001 in 2007
but they don't write mmm it's [ __ ]
bad anyway so that's you were on paper
you had money yep you did for how many
years that was about the six and a half
year mark was when I said I got a bounce
so for six and a half years you did
something that made you look like you
had something on paper because you were
burnt out and didn't feel right you gave
it back which in essence may it meant
you made no money correct so you're
basically starting over yep yep thousand
percent tell them one more time yeah
yeah I started over because I wanted to
feel aligned - yeah and I'm not gonna
grab nothing nothing that's right so
and II I built my that store for him and
at 30 [ __ ] for I was worth nothing
like let that hang in the air
I mean yeah I needed to hang in the air
because everybody like looks at us and
in you know I just don't I wish people
understood the one thing I really wish
they understood is that dude I totally
get the chasing the Lambos and all this
I actually get it but at the end of the
day as somebody who lived that and tried
that and thought that it was gonna be
rad I'm just telling you [ __ ] sucks
like it will drain your soul in a way
you can't predict until you're doing it
yeah and one superfund up front like at
halftime you're like this was exactly
right the first three years were awesome
exactly because but not because of the
money it was awesome because I was
getting more powerful so I was learning
business I was like a lock like this is
amazing I felt like I controlled my
destiny I was like this is the [ __ ] and
then like after a while it started to
take from me
it started to erode me as a person and I
was losing my relationships it was just
it was gnarly and my wife pulled me
aside was like this is now damaging our
relationship because I was so unhappy at
work I don't want to talk about it at
work which meant I didn't talk to her
about the number one thing in my life
he was just bananas I was just doing it
ass-backwards this is all pre like
social media so when I went in and left
it was like I have no idea what I'm
gonna do I just know I'm gonna pursue
something that makes me feel a lot
happen next so I go and I quit and they
say the famous words which were we could
do this without you but we don't want to
and so I was like well I've already done
the hard thing which is quit so let me
tell you the truth of who I am cuz I've
been telling you that all I want is to
get rich and that you know do anything
to build this business that's not true
yeah and it was camaraderie is a higher
value for me than pursuing money meaning
and purpose of what I'm really driven by
I need to be passionate about what I'm
doing and so for three very different
pretty close men I articulates my game
so yes yeah it was this pretty on point
with it yeah so in the meeting when I
quit I was [ __ ] mess so no there I was
like and then they said look let's go
out to dinner and talk and then once we
got there then yeah I was back not then
but when we did quest which is of course
what is born out of this moment of
crisis we were equal partners
so this tech thing you had yeah you quit
you guys calm down
decide to become equal 1/3 1/3 I assume
yeah I'm just asking yep 33 30 and what
and in what literally you went from that
to starting quest yep a
direct-to-consumer yep like health yeah
so literally and we went from technology
to food and everybody was like what the
hell are you doing like that said it was
our step this was 2009 when we started
conceiving it and then 2010 when we
officially started selling and you sold
it first direct-to-consumer yo yes what
was the original quest bar model what
version of direct-to-consumer so we were
online it was online only you would come
to our website and we would sell you
there literally just off of our website
how we paid media traffic no we were
doing influencer mark exclusively but it
wasn't called that really back then at
least we didn't know that so we were
just out there on Facebook yeah
literally like I would drive this is a
real story
if you seemed like you might be an
influencer I would drive the [ __ ]
bars to your house if you were anywhere
near us and like park around the block
because my car was such a piece of [ __ ]
I want you to see that like we were just
you know putting this all together and I
would deliver the bar in the hopes that
I could make some sort of impression on
you about what we were doing were you
savvy enough already hoping they would
post on social or even was it just
definitely yeah social yes a thousand
percent our whole thing they didn't know
how valuable correct and that's the ARB
correct yeah it was and it was I mean
you obviously know and you've talked a
lot about this it was a really cool time
and if you were doing something real and
it was beautiful and people could really
resonate with what you were doing so our
thing was community community community
add value to people's lives don't try to
sell them [ __ ] this was not just social
like he probably and he's gonna answer
it maybe not but like this was like even
when like a forum post or on your own
blog like attention was in a lot of
different places back then yeah yeah
dude forums we live done for me it was
crazy guys forums and ways worse
versions have read it yes and it changes
so fast like the one just constant in
the game is that whatever you're doing
today is not gonna work six months from
now so like my strengths because I'm
unemotional about where the attention is
bro I'm telling you my can't wait like
I'm like literally sometimes laying like
a flatbed flight on a red-eye and I'm
gonna be like no it's just the last time
I thought of it so let me use that
example and like dude I can't wait for
there not to be
social media right like not a bit cuz
I'm gonna be dominating whatever the
[ __ ] is happening and then then
everybody will understand my thesis more
because right now they don't understand
that I've been day trading attention my
whole life rent and that this just
happens to be when I most popped so this
is what you think I am
oh no I get the game trust me I know you
do so ok so then you built a monster
[ __ ] company we built a monster
[ __ ] company and it blew up and in
five years we weren't from not existing
to being valued at over a billion
dollars doing hundreds of millions in
revenue and it was in manufacturing dude
like really think about that it's one
thing to do it in software no no you're
preaching yeah it was when the bananas
when the cocoa trees are [ __ ] wiped
out by the rain people don't get it all
the like almonds no my team in-house I'm
like guys we're going in and pitching
content they're meeting before this was
their supplier for for the fava beans
which is the core ingredient the product
like died and the family selling the
farm and like they can't make cocoa
puffs that's real that's real you know
better than I do
it's crazy and you get locked into we
got locked into an almond contract at
one point that has a material impact on
your business so it's like in fact
somebody was just asking me outside like
what makes you unique and my thing is
I've spent the last almost 20 years
building businesses like sitting down
forecasting sales meetings dealing with
retailers who are pissed like trying to
figure out channel conflict what is
channel conflict you know what I mean
like when you're having to do all that
[ __ ] suddenly coming and putting a mic
in front of you it's just like you've
got a wealth of [ __ ] that you've had to
do and encounter to draw on are you in
when you first discovered me we got to
know each other is that the part that
was most interesting to you that like as
you were starting to build your content
personal brand and content ambitions and
doing it well they're like oh you're
like oh Gary's like me like he's an
operator and does content as a person
the the real answer that question is I
was so pissed off by you really yeah
wait listen to this listen to this thing
so I start doing before it's called
social media all that stuff I you know
we're doing it and we're [ __ ] doing
it better than anybody else I was about
community when no one was talking about
that is about authenticity and
transparency before those became
buzzwords like just going [ __ ] ham
because that's where I was right I'm not
chasing money anymore [ __ ] I'm
doing something I care about I'm saving
my mom and my sister like this is real
for me so because of that it was coming
from somewhere so real we were doing
social before anybody else creating all
of her own content everything and it was
so like for real I want to touch
people's lives and so we blew up and I
felt like I'm King [ __ ] like I get it I
get something nobody else gets that the
number one most powerful marketing
vehicles being a good person like this
is [ __ ] crazy like we're living in
this weird time we're just because I
actually give a [ __ ] and if I did
something like my product didn't work
for you what if and I'll not only will I
take it back refund you I'll give you
more for free like whatever right and
it's just right time then my team starts
going Tom you've got a step out front
dude you've got to step out front we
want to start filming you and I was like
absolutely [ __ ] not that is so weird
like I want to be in the background
definitely not my personality to want to
step out front and then you started
popping off yeah and they kept rubbing
you in my face and they're like look at
this [ __ ] look what he's doing
dude like he's popping off people who
really listened to his message and I was
listening I'm loving this [ __ ] guy's
real every word out of his mouth is
[ __ ] real and if people take his
advice and that's the thing I used to
laugh about I was like guaranteed most
people are not actually paid advice but
I'm gonna start taking his advice
because it's real and I can see and I
saw that you saw from a personal
branding perspective what I missed
and so this was probably about four
years ago I was like alright this dude
[ __ ] figured it out and now I'm in
second place I do not [ __ ] like
second place so I need to start hustling
and I need to get a show and I need to
do the [ __ ] and so we would literally
just like how do we bring all this stuff
that I've been doing behind the scenes
and how do we translate it in front of
the camera awesome but it really born
out of watching you leapfrog me because
you were its man I have so much you know
I always loved pointing to you and and
you know you were early client of a
no-talent which you know as an evolving
business for us here and I remember just
like leave I don't know maybe you were
in that sit or Andy but I remember like
walking I'm like guys he's super smart
like he's like doing it for the exact
right reason like he's gonna absolutely
like rent the milk like if you remember
and this is just truth I was like hey
well we can help you build it for
yourself but you're like now it's
valuable for me to pay the fee I can see
every nuance but it was like I remember
that meeting so clearly but what I loved
was you built an actual business real
quick I'm not even sure I know this
quest sold well we sold a piece so I
still have massive ownership I'm just
letting it all day today so who did it
sell to so we had we brought in private
private equity yeah brought in private
equity but just the valuation was so
crazy that the dollars it was pure
diversification on our part so now all
the social was operating it now so my
two partners are still there
they brought in a new CEO just like
theirs for the CEO no I was the
president and so businesses go through
phases you know and who's right in one
minutes not necessarily right in the
next so when I left they just changed
things up a bit and and off to the races
they went for the audience so I've
launched a new company called impact
theory which literally no [ __ ] when
I got into business it was because I
couldn't get the films made that I
wanted to make now admittedly my whole
thesis around what film can be changed
in the intervening time and now I've
become all about impact but and this is
one of the things you and I talked about
in the beginning is I was telling
everybody look what Disney just did by
buying Marvel like you don't understand
what's going on and I pitched it to you
and you said my whole life is predicated
on the fact that Disney just bought
Marvel this [ __ ] so I was like
alright so my whole thing is Disney did
something nobody else did which is they
told one kind of story from a thousand
different angles and because of that
their brand means something so if I say
I'm gonna go see a Paramount movie or a
Universal movie you know nothing about
it but if I say I'm gonna go see a
Disney movie you already know something
so I'm all about impact I'm all about
reaching out and touching people's lives
in it for real way and hopefully we'll
get into that because I've recently been
really really strong to it here yes
right now yeah that would be amazing
you're going to take it there right so
basically yes but then like go right
into yeah so I wanna really touch
people's lives I have I've worked in the
inner cities a lot I started when I was
18 for extra credit I did an eight-week
assignment with this little kid who was
like drug and alcohol impact it totally
office I just out of his mind and he
would freak out when I would try to help
with his homework cry just a nightmare
and then when I'd say I have to leave
then he would beg and plead and cry and
all that and I would stay
week five I realized he's trolling me
and that he actually knows exactly what
he's doing I thought this [ __ ] kid
sharp so then I've got a little respect
for him
and at week six you have to tell him I'm
only coming for two more weeks
so I tell him he goes nuclear I mean
just I've never seen a human that
distraught and so finally I'm like is it
because I said I'm only coming for two
more weeks he says yes I said look man
because by now like I really have bonded
with this kid or so I'm like as long as
I live in Los Angeles as long as I live
in Los Angeles I'll help you with your
homework but you have to do it the
second I get here no more of this like
fighting and stuff that becomes an eight
naff year relationship completely
changes my life I didn't know it at the
time but he's being abused by his
adoptive mother he gets taken out they
make me the Guardian I have to help me
into foster care I mean it was like some
heavy [ __ ] for an early twenty-something
kid from Tacoma and going through that
process I just had this overwhelming
feeling that this kid could be something
he could be really special like he's a
beautiful human being but he's never
going to be because what he's been
taught is so limiting that and so I used
to take him to movies in Beverly Hills
because I was broke but movies cost the
same and I wanted him to see beautiful
places ya wanted him to have something
to aspire to
so anyway flash-forward 15 years now
I've got about 3,000 employees and about
a thousand of them grew up hard as hell
like one kid held his stepfather while
he bled to death from a gunshot wound to
the head
another his sister was shot in the heart
with an ak-47 in his front yard when she
was 12 I mean just like story after
story after story and I had that same
feeling again these are amazing [ __ ]
people dude
but they're never gonna do anything and
so back in the early days of Quest I
interviewed everybody if you wanted to
work there you're gonna interview for me
whether you janitor or EVP assails
didn't matter yeah and so I had this
magic Genie question because I wanted to
know what you were really about and so
heya magic genies about to show up the
grant you one wish and one wish only
can't be more wishes or to cure cancer
bring somebody back from the dead it's
got to be for you what do you want dude
I must ask that question I'm not kidding
300 times what are the odds every single
person give me the same answer literally
every single which person $1,000,000
what and I was like I had that reaction
so at person at person 10 I actually
said to the team are you guys [ __ ]
with me like are you prepping them
beforehand because there's it doesn't
make any sense you can't get a house in
LA for a million dollars it's a magic
[ __ ] Genie you don't ask for a money
machine or a trillion dollars just for a
million dollars they have to so that
they have to uh pay taxes but
Sixsmith detours the capital gains that
they kept at least 800 her like it was
so crazy to me and so what it showed me
was friend apologize the million dollar
thing really [ __ ] with me too because
the 1% of earners in America the bottom
of it starts at 440 and this million
[ __ ] with everyone yeah I wish the
answer to that question was 440 because
then would who then it would be based on
the merit of reality the Delta between
440 and a million is pretty significant
right and everybody thinks a million is
just the beginning of any level success
mm-hmm it's I think about it all the
time anyway keep going so it it was the
only truthful answer is it was
heartbreaking and I thought all right
their frame of reference is what's
keeping them stuck it's not that they're
not smart it's not that they can't learn
they can so it is entirely that they
don't believe that their energies will
be rewarded with powerful knowledge so
they don't read a books I don't think
anything will come of it they don't
dream big enough they don't think that
they kitchen so I was just like I'm
gonna get some more if you're watching
on Facebook or Instagram live right now
Tom and I are gonna Tom's about the
segue into what do you really want to
talk about but then we're gonna do a
couple questions it's gary vee team at
vaynermedia calm put your question in
the title and your phone number in the
body there it is some people are just
born with it go ahead what do you want
to segue into so my whole thing is how
do you help people like that at scale
yes how do you really do it so you're
gonna build a media company around that
correct I love it so there it is I know
it's [ __ ] right Thank You Man what
you have to do is do hot you what you
have to do is follow what we're doing at
Boehner I got to show you actually
obviously we're gonna be seeing each
other probably a lot more given what an
ounce in a minute you just made the best
decision of your life that when you
decided to join me and create with me
Boehner speakers did you and we knew
we've known each other for eight years
cool well uh it's even better than you
thought right
yeah that's all I needed to hear in
fairness yeah he actually said that
outside what'd he say there were no
cameras that it was better than he
thought
he said I knew it was gonna be big I
knew I was gonna be special but it's
actually better because what I do is
sand it's ice and bag everything about
it and me and they like you're so good
bro I just want to give you honestly
you're such a good dude I'm so pumped
what we're alluding to reload right now
everyone's confused as we're gonna be in
we announce the Vayner speakers as you
guys know zach is the CEO we worked
together for a long time when he was at
CAA and we had a great run a big love
for see a speaking and all that Peter
Jacobs big shout out to you I love you
and we're gonna announce our roster
probably in a month or so but uh Thomas
is one of the first who's with us
exclusively we're gonna be doing a
speaking so we're gonna be hanging I
have a funny feeling four or five events
next year we'll be speaking the same
event so I'll be able to see you but
what was that going with that [ __ ] there
was an interesting segue and I got
excited but the banner speaker saying I
want to show you something we're working
on at vaynermedia
there's like gonna transcend content and
I think you'll need to do to be a great
2023 storyteller from a high/low
standpoint just the sheer volume of
content good to be right kind of like
what I do what you're okay so anything
else you want to see before we get into
questions no I'm at I'm ready let's do
it
have you been doing investing like you
made a lot of money yep
that's not as fun as it sounds right
it's not I hate it not completely almost
my thing is I'd rather I want to do some
sort of like incubator
I don't invest anymore I want to find
kids that and you and old people like I
don't give a [ __ ] people that have like
a three to seven million dollar business
and I want them to give me 49 percent of
it and then I want to like just plug it
in and make it to a hundred yeah I think
I can do that consistently we had a
closed deal soon they [ __ ] up I love
when people overplay their hands right
love it don't overplay your hands kids a
lot of people fake it and posture if you
run into a real winner like Tom and I we
might say no and then the whole deal is
dead that's what happened you overplayed
his [ __ ] hand sorry I'm doing some
talking who's this Josh I'm amazing
brother you're on the askgaryvee show
with me and Tommy be
are you watching clearly you're watching
how's the show going so far Tom's
killing it right like he's completely
charming your pants off right good Tom
is the man I'm watching a lot of impact
theory with my boy simon Sinek like took
over the Internet
yeah that was crazy like yo Simon's got
a super viral video
by the way we made the best video of all
time I made a video that recorded me
rebutting Simon uncertain things about
Millennials while I watched it for the
first time Wow we played it they're
recording me I'm talking over the two of
you and I think the video would have had
a trillion views the reality is I have
so much respect in Admiral of Simon that
I felt like and I'm so teen millennial
and I hate what's happening with people
misbranding them then I felt like I was
two teeth and I didn't wanted to become
a miiverse Simon thing so I never aired
it's a piece of amazing content it's
that I have too much admiration for
Simon and I felt like my energy was kind
of like my trash talk radda edit out a
bunch of stuff in trash talk kappa so
three because my energy was in a place
where i switched into the competitive
you know anyway sorry tom tom that video
[ __ ] what the jerk i was bananas
bananas and that was that was all him
dude he just smashed it I know he just
smashed it do you feel anyway
nonetheless what's your question brother
yeah so before I get into my question
you talked about trash talk 3 I've also
been following that I think that a major
key for anybody who is looking to like
make some extra money or who takes their
day job so if you're listening and maybe
this happens after and definitely check
out trash talk series by Gary is amazing
why did you shut up that dude it you
know what a fact that shadow it's kind
of wild like Tom and me like I like
practical operating practitioners like I
love that [ __ ] like learning how to make
$230 a week extra on offer up and on
Craigslist and Facebook marketplace and
eBay is just smart because not only for
a lot of people eight hundred bucks a
month nine hundred bucks a month is
game-changing and you
I share the perspective of seeing other
parts of the world where [ __ ] two
hundred bucks a month is a big deal
number two it teaches you [ __ ] anyway go
ahead which'll question cuz we're about
to hang up on your face take a quarter
at a corporate employee I lost you for a
second oh brother one more time how do
you change a culture and a corporation
as an employee Tom yeah man I think the
the real honest answer is unless it is
being supported from the top down it
will never ever work so you can go to
them and if you can get your leadership
on board then you've got a shot if you
cannot get them on board it will never
work and if the culture is that
dysfunctional my advice to you is if the
top isn't gonna get on get out yeah I'm
gonna be even more black and white even
though I know exactly what it was saying
the answer is you can't even if you like
for example me I'm like a really good
dude like but still if it's pitched in
to me I have to manipulate it into mine
or I don't like it as much that's just
what the leader does you agree with that
Andy it's funny right you guys have like
strategize how to make me feel like it's
mine otherwise you know I'll never do
Seth you're laughing right what happens
you guys just sit up there and try to
figure out how do we make Gary feel like
this is his otherwise he will completely
not support it right yeah so anyway
brother listen if you're in a company
look culture to me is really interesting
I think companies build it from the get
so if you have the original founder
there and it's not good get the [ __ ] out
because she or he was never on board if
you don't have the original founder and
they've been there for more than a year
or two get the [ __ ] out cuz they changed
it
I literally tell my whole company and
all hands on company meetings hey real
quick by the way before they on this
meeting if I ever sell this place quit
the next day cuz everything I promised
you is not true anymore so I'm with Tom
Mann like company like like unless you
miraculously have leverage on the
singular a leader of the company which
even in a three-person partnership there
is an a within that you will not be able
to change the culture because culture
100%
from top you're either CEO that likes
happiness and impact and like I why we
have a good culture as I hate negativity
I'm weirded out by it and so because I'm
also the best money earner nobody has
leverage on me so I fire other people
that don't do good things to my culture
unless you have a leader like that that
means they care about the money don't
you care about the money
the culture has no [ __ ] prayer yeah
now on culture man is is literally
everything everything my thing is my new
like absolute obsession is emotional
safety and it's one of those things
people don't talk about business feel
super weird to say words like emotional
safety but I'm telling you right now
like if whatever you do whether you're
starting your own business or you're in
a business look for somewhere where you
can have emotional safety because coming
into work and feeling good about it is a
big deal and I think there are two
metrics and this is really gonna get
people in a weird place metric number
one laughter how often do people laugh
you have to [ __ ] pay attention to
that and then number two and dude the
first time this really occurred to me
was I was in your office and I was
looking out and I saw two people put
their arms around each other I thought
wow that's interesting and so when you
build emotional safety you will just see
the people connect and bond in a way
that becomes like physically Express
vaynermedia weddings their absurdity
lifelong friendships that's trust
management emotional state agency being
built in Bali right now by Shawn clay on
consider like this is like in perpetuity
like I tell everybody it's a little it's
like a framework I totally agree my big
one that's more practical I like yours
better I hate that I have to be the
straight man but it's a good one for a
lot of people listening is voluntary
retention like the way I judge Vayner is
how many people that I really give a
[ __ ] about that I think are awesome
people and are awesome at their job have
left Boehner the numbers staggeringly
low I know we got something yeah totally
you know thank you for the question
brother hey Jerry like Google did a
study on with epic teens and they call
it project Aristotle and he was the
biggest piece of making a successful
team so it's backed by research Google
actually having son it makes sense it
makes
but here's the problem google stuck
because they're a publicly traded
company and that's why they have the
entire company walk out on them
they're stuck your guy's life is binary
like either your make as a business
either you care more about the money or
more about the feeling you feel in
running it I am I would be fired by
every publicly trip
if Vader went public I'd be fired fired
fast
I have easily taken this business from
40 to 140 million in revenue and 200
over the kind of holding company and I'm
making way less money today than we did
it 40 god that's so interesting and I
really hope people are listening no no
for real hold on because that dude
that's the juice once you understand
that in your life [ __ ] you're
either going to be chasing money or
you're gonna be chasing fulfillment and
nary the twain shall meet and for when
you when you chase fulfilment you may
also build a massive [ __ ] company I'm
gonna do both I I always say and I'm
making up the rules that I'm gonna be
the best entrepreneur because I'm gonna
make the most money and have the most
impact on other entrepreneurs ya know I
love that and I think there's a third
part of that that I clearly see in your
company and is literally the the
cornerstone of impact theory and that is
people over everything
it's the connection that each person
feels the trust from that we'll be able
to do something extraordinary because
when you believe in people your guard is
down there's motion invested yeah where
does entitlement fall into it because I
will tell you one of the flaws in me
running Boehner over the last seven
years and we've gotten a lot better in
the last two years and well on our way
but I definitely created a macro culture
of entitlement because I had people over
everything and I took everything on my
head yeah so it's two things one it is
absolute high standards so you have to
have standards explain what they are and
know what people have to do in order to
be in and that sort of safety circle and
then the other is your boy Ray Dalio
mm-hmm looking at your girl Lindsey down
there so ray and his whole notion of say
truth here truth that that is the one
time I would say when I read that book
it changed me forever as an entrepreneur
because it was a failure of my
imagination to believe that you could
hold him thousands of people in an
organization to and this is how he says
it and this is so true even if you have
a criticism that you're
take to the grave that you don't even
say to your significant other you still
have an obligation to voice that super
fast that is absolutely not a strength
of mine radical candor is something I
continue to evolve into hmm it just
doesn't you know I'm really great when
[ __ ] comes natural to me like I I just
don't like money and I will use money
and I will and I'm really emotionally
strong I will help the other people much
like it's really funny radical candor
and that even to that level is absurd no
question is a strength of his and others
that I haven't had and now I've gotten
dramatic my brother had a J's was about
much better at it naturally I've gotten
a lot lot better and it's been a
strength of mine look today we fired
somebody that it [ __ ] I've been
thinking bout it for nine days super not
pumped I feel like [ __ ] right now but if
I don't do it the whole [ __ ] thing
crumbles yeah it gets toxic for other
things so people over everything doesn't
mean keeping people around even though
you've manipulated your own self and
believing they're better off with you
than not with you
true but here's part of why I say people
over everything and it doesn't mean that
I'm just gonna let you get away with
murder it's like you've got the
collective and for the collective to
have trust and all of that then they
have to know that if somebody isn't
living up to it they're not carrying
their end of the bargain that they're
gonna be like Oh like simple ask but
that it's going to be done openly and
respectfully and that you're gonna help
them transition out gracefully unless
somebody's just like willfully horrible
this is where ego of hiring
vulnerability people hire people they
end up being awful and they don't want
to MIT they made the mistake and they
keep around sure yeah
yeah this is yeah this is Khaled Khaled
it's Gary Vaynerchuk you're on the
askgaryvee show with Tom billion life is
good my man hunt man thanks for having
me on your show I really really
appreciate it I'm gonna get straight to
the point cuz I know your time is really
expensive I just had a question you know
this is something to do with my life
I've been in the exotic car business for
a very long time and you know it's a
very expensive business to get into
I somewhat in my shoes you know an
entrepreneur you know don't have you
know a lot of
funding mine me at all actually so I
have a large list of contacts I've been
networking for a long time it's not the
grade to make sandy shake so I met a lot
of people a lot of celebrities you know
Ava celebrities you know music artists
all walks of life and I've been doing
this for about ten years
I'm 26 now so I've been in the game for
about 10 years do not have an Instagram
link at the bottom of your website when
you're in the most visual and kind of
exotic car world I you know I definitely
mean I have a really nice Instagram I
mean I haven't you but you know you want
a nice website with some [ __ ] exotic
[ __ ] animal on top of a cool car but
you have literally the Facebook and
Twitter logo at the bottom but not the
Instagram one I know so that was
actually I dealership that I worked for
it not got it I'm currently working for
myself now thankfully a broker respect
it and now I'm working all by myself and
brokering deals you know taking clients
because clients come back for me they
don't come back dealership they come
back very leveraged exactly the question
my question is now basically I have the
experience I have the clients you know
the demand is there I'm getting calls
every time you know a concert in town
anything celebrities need cards for
rentals then you want to buy a new car
I'm trying to figure out how how do I
get to the next level Gary as far as
getting funding to start a company like
that how do I find investors who have
the capital and are looking for you know
that kind of a business don't owe your
entire [ __ ] life is interacting with
people that have that kind of money and
you know that's very true Gary I mean I
mean people are billionaires I mean all
sorts of people but here's the biggest
you know thing I have to overcome over
comma I feel like every time this is an
objection is that I'm young I don't have
like per se a track record rather eyes
brother number one is the number one
mistake that people make in life let
alone business is they say no for the
other party
without asking word yeah like no now if
you like you know look I have empathy I
hate asking anybody for anything so
you've got these clients it doesn't feel
appropriate from transitioning to you
just rented them out something and you
know you're like hey give me a million
bucks but inevitably you've now
interacted with some [ __ ] ballers an
eighth time a tenth time some of them
have you been shown a liking towards you
because they see them
Tom and I'm sure do this just knowing it
him a little bit like when we see
ourselves and people you just gravitate
towards it you're like cuz you're just
always very aware that circumstance has
helped you so much
and so while I'm always in the business
of helping somebody out when it feels
right you just live it that way right
that's just the [ __ ] game look
brother you're gonna have to ask
somebody for the money right and a kid
like you who's more like a kid like me
you're not gonna get it from traditional
VCS they don't invest in [ __ ] like this
and we don't have the pedigree to get
money from those people you have the
pedigree to get money from other
hustlers for sure well here goes nothing
Gary you ready to invest in my company
or what a hundred thousand percent not
here's why you must have even missed it
a few minutes ago or you skipped over it
I literally just said eleven minutes ago
that I hate [ __ ] investing I know I'm
just messing with you I appreciate you
having me on your show and I did want to
tell you you know I I never kept it
above me to do other side hustles
like going to garage sales or picking up
line Birds and scooters and charging
them I mean I began all the things no
trying to save up money in bed for you
mail look there's a lot of your vibe
that's interesting man like like you
come from an industry that I'm always
like scared of it's the slippiest of the
slick but you're articulating yourself
even like in my intuitive feelings which
I go by all the time
look man listen I really appreciate this
let me say something to everybody who's
listening the reason so many kids are
starting companies and want to get
venture capital is if they fail they
don't have to pay anybody back I think
there's another reason there's a lot of
region but I but this is one that nobody
talks about Tom yeah fair you give up 25
percent of your company the amount of
people that I think are starting
companies
startups that already know on day one
that they have no chance of success is
remarkably high but the capital a raise
allows them to live the lifestyle with
no damage to their credit
there's too much [ __ ] money in the
system here's why I'm telling you that
if you really believe in yourself bro
and you've been doing something for ten
years and this is gonna brain-fuck
everybody on my team I hate when people
have credit card debt like it's my
freaked out of freaked out right or dead
in general I will tell you that I've
been at my best when I knew that I was
operating not taking any chance and when
I'm willing to do that I'm willing to do
anything to get the money like [ __ ]
loan shark [ __ ] like mafioso breaks my
life [ __ ] you know why because if I
understand the interest and I understand
I can get I can figure it out even
though I'm paying fifty percent interest
let alone five the days of getting money
from the bank people don't think about
that anymore but let me give you where
I'm actually going you know many kids
should be asking their parents for money
or their rich aunt a lot the problem is
they're not thinking about it right they
need to walk into the rich aunt and say
aunt sally i need a hundred fifty k but
I will pay you back and if I if it dies
I will then get a job and I will pay you
back five thousand bucks every quarter
for the rest of my [ __ ] life
people are not putting their [ __ ]
balls on the line you are doing that
anymore
everybody wants to raise money and give
up new whatever son of a company worth
nothing you don't have to risk it when
you're delirious the reason I'm giving
you this advice is you've been doing it
for a decade you feel intuitively right
to me so I'm saying to you do what Tom
and I did and live the practical life
not this [ __ ] life live the
practical life man I and you know what
that was the first step for me to move
forward is to stop trying to live up to
everybody's expectations stop looking at
everybody else and humble myself and
actually how's my friend move in you
know what the wrath no share do do do
you really you know humility for the
alpha male and woman in their 20s human
is the secret [ __ ] sauce but now
let's push it did you actually do that
yeah I did because here's the thing I
was always trying to buy the most
expensive stuff because we were looking
everybody would have stopped doing that
and I just focused on myself and I
accepted myself for what position I'm in
and I'm like okay Khaled your [ __ ]
shits in yeah in the toilet right Callie
yes you know you need to need to get
your stuff together lower overall
living cost down yes and just like do
every little side hustle that I can cuz
I can maximize my time now that I've
been working for myself so I could do a
bunch of little stuff you know at night
I'm doing the scooters I mean I'm doing
4050 scooters a night we're going to
garage sales picking up stuff free off
Craigslist you know I'm a marketing
stuff online for people Google ads I'm
doing a bunch of stuff and I have my
cousin real quick it's real quick cuz
there's a lot of bubbling up of like
Gary you're pushing people to work too
hard and all this stuff and I'm watching
it I'm like I love one elitists who work
their faces off to make a bunch of money
then tell everybody else not to work
hard so so so to me if you love what
you're doing and you're happy and you're
mentally and physically healthy do you
I'm not judging anybody about doing
anything but it's all about
self-awareness and could and putting a
framework around where you don't keep up
with the Joneses you know I want to put
my finger on something so your your vibe
changed so much when you got into the
pocket on where you're confident humans
lead with belief in the beginning you
you didn't have that belief cuz you're
stretching for the fancy cars and all
that but when you slid back to I'm
living in a studio apartment with you
know six other dudes I believed in you
and if you came to me with that hustling
you're like look [ __ ] I have
boiled my life down to nothing I have no
expenses I eat Top Ramen and I grinded
the [ __ ] out from the floor of my
friend's bathroom I will make this [ __ ]
if you give me money I will spend the
rest of my life paying you back if it
fails and you have that belief because
you actually believe it you know it's
true you know you can do that you're
operating from a position of strength
now just your energy is gonna convince
people to get on board with you but when
you try to posture hustle like from a
place it's not real that's where people
don't buy into you and
beauty is like that's what I sense like
the whole time dude this is really cool
by the way this is the kissing cousin to
why I want kids to stop taking money
from their parents
it all comes on the same thing it's
called fake environments either you live
on your merit or you don't
mm-hmm yeah I've been on my own since I
was 15 and I'm very thankful for it
because my parents instilled me with the
right morals and the right hustle at a
young age and then I you know it's twist
to be a man on my own and I work
mechanic shop and i sticked in the car
thing for a long time really so it's
like my passion too so it goes hand in
hand I enjoy everything that I do still
like work alone even when I'm working
you live in Atlanta I do live in Atlanta
oh man send me an email to Gary at
vaynermedia comm I want to high-five you
when I come for Superbowl dude that
would be so awesome
and that wasn't like secret cold cuz I
don't code for like I want a fancy card
[ __ ] I hate that [ __ ] I mean I just
don't actually high-five you dude dude I
would be a pleasure to be any within
your proxy awesome and thank you for the
call
fake environments I want to wrap up with
this okay you get it because last time
scooter made us do another call and like
turned out so awesome got it Tom I'm so
about this fakin barbets if I can
convince people that credit cards are
bad that parents money is bad mmm that
posturing is bad the happiness is absurd
this is absurd also I want to get people
on obsessive thinking so one of the
things people always ask me okay what's
your secret to your success and normally
say reading but I'll say that there's
actually something else I do that people
it's hard to articulate but here it goes
there's a great question that Peter teal
asks how do you take your 10 year plan
and make it happen in six months so if
you obsessively think about how do I
accelerate this like how do I what's
that quantum leap forward and for him to
be thinking about that like the
collapsing down to very little expense
so that he can get into a place that's
actually winning win with that build
like a package up that he can go pitch
to people and say like look I only want
whatever I want to flip more scooters
whatever so he's getting in it you know
a thousand or 10,000 instead of you know
four hundred thousand then he can build
that momentum he and you just keep going
upstream upstream upstream
what's interesting you and I disagree on
the use of the word patience like so
violently these so my thing is [ __ ]
patience literally and but the thing is
I always tell people I know what Gary
means and Gary means play the long
patience micro speed a thousand percent
the problem is when people hear patience
they get in a passive mess yes some
[ __ ] psychotic about that you used
the word passive though yeah exactly you
can't let people get into a passive that
situation towards patients yeah but what
I'm saying is when people hear that word
out of anyone's mouth I understand they
go in the wrong line of everybody
semantically articulating the
manipulation of words to their non
meeting it's interesting so here's how
like I love women like I love like like
the amount of judgment that is being
thrown at me right now in circles around
people manipulating the words that I'm
like it's absurd like patience is not
passive so my thing is how do people
react to it I couldn't agree more but
the reality is is if we are now in a
place where we can't allow the words to
actually mean what they mean we have to
challenge that conversation as well
because now you're getting into how
people filter everything and now we're
talking about the most important P which
is perspective if they're filter is
taking it then you're you that's what
gets so interesting about having to do
this one-on-one versus through content
content is vulnerable in its macro it's
super interesting [ __ ] very interesting
and I that on this particular thing like
I'll say forget the list because you and
I are saying the same the last thing I
want to do is argue that when we get to
the point
thousand percent and I'm with you my
thing is how do you get people to
realize that momentum is the thing that
I think matters so if you have you ever
been in like an aboveground swimming
pool you can start walking in a circle
and it creates the the vortex and then
you could pick your feet up and it's all
the thing I was talking to you about
that I got to walk you through of like
what you need to do for your studio to
like win the world literally what
internally for a few minutes was called
momentum marketing nice you can't people
yeah who's this Royce
like Royce Clayton if you know Royce
clean is leaving in the comments Claire
like if I forget that Google exists
these these like so grew up in an Amish
or suffer to Giants Royce its Gary
Vaynerchuk and Ernie askgaryvee show
with Tom bill you oh my god holy [ __ ] I
was listening you guys live oh my god
it's so cool how you doing nice wait
what are you from rice bleep Cincinnati
Ohio
are you a Bengals fan Oh big time but
you're a gone off your cursing could you
sum up in your game but I appreciate it
man you do know that the Jets beat the
Bengals in a huge playoff game in
Cincinnati in 2010 right oh I'm sure all
right I mean yeah wait Andy wait I put
in like a couple questions which
whatever this one you want Andy yeah Tom
he should love your stuff here I listen
and watch a lot of impact Theory love it
I saw you uh sorry I listened to you on
the Joe Rogan experience a couple of
months ago and you mentioned how you
heard how some people believe that your
you have to be a natural corn
entrepreneur or you can turn into one if
your entrepreneurial tendencies and you
you disagreed with the fact the fact
that a lot of people out there believe
it just be a natural born entrepreneur I
was wondering I know Gary you always say
how you're only a natural born
entrepreneur there's there's no thought
if you've ever worked a job in your life
that you you could be one so I get some
worried I think that you be an ask or
not so can you can you become an
entrepreneur or do you have to be a
natural born one well good news like
I'll lose this right now because
everybody's an entrepreneur now and most
of them are not natural born
entrepreneurs now let's talk about
people that are successful entrepreneurs
and not successful entrepreneurs that's
fair and that that's a big deal then
there's also people bleeding
entrepreneurship with operators so I
think operators are
something that can be taught and those
individuals she and he are incredible
cielos co-founders as the number two
guys
there is a mental strength that comes
along with your the last line of defense
that is by definition what
entrepreneurship is built around that I
do think we underestimate in what is
like comes natural but I think that
they're like I think that being a
successful entrepreneur is more of a
skill than a top behavior in the
framework of my perspective being taught
to be an operator is I see every day
most great CEOs are people that were
taught to be an operator many of them
are considered co-founders but would
have not been successful without the
energy of the human that was there to
eat the pressure and actually lead the
company is how I see it Tom yeah so this
is one that I I have lived the exact
opposite so I started out my parents
taught me to be a good employee to keep
my head down to as little work as
possible and avoid punishment I'll sauce
yes I had a newspaper route I was too
afraid to go knock on the doors to
collect the money so for like two years
I delivered the paper for half the money
I could have gotten I never stole
somebody's flowers out of the yard and
sitting back like none of that yes so
but then to get what I wanted which was
to make films on my terms I had to
generate the capital to generate the
combos to do that whoo Lambo well you
said earlier you were like you were into
some of the flashy stuff I get why other
people chase you weren't no I was
chasing I wanted money to build a studio
got it so I knew that I had to learn a
certain set of skills now my whole thing
comes down to humans are the ultimate
adaptation machine literally what we do
is adapt that is our design so you can
take there was a woman who swam the
Bering Strait and she turned literally
over a year of cold exposure turned
white adipose tissue which is the fat
into what's called brown adipose tissue
which generates more heat now people
will believe it at the body right
nobody's here telling me that I'm crazy
for that so easy to show people that you
can change your body but for some reason
people don't think that you can change
the mind is a question I completely only
believe you can change the mind which is
now getting into an interesting
semantics
so keep going yeah yes no no I'm sorry
I'm gonna go keep going but you're gonna
know buddy appreciate you're gonna
answer sure does that mean everybody is
born
a natural born entrepreneur that means
everybody else it means everybody that
meets minimum requirements and we will
have to talk about that okay so that
gets Ken that's fine that gets into a
different place yes so if you meet
minimum requirements and some people do
not but what if you're Hakeem Olajuwon
yeah what if you Tom are actually Hakeem
Olajuwon
okay so Hakeem Olajuwon it was born in
Africa doesn't realize he's a natural
great basketball player but he's not
exposed to it yeah but actually was born
a natural like what if you actually were
just cuz the environment you were in so
you say yeah I was a natural born I was
in a work environment because that's
where I'm going with this which is you
were an environment where your parents
created the environment to eliminate the
entrepreneurial right spirit but that it
was down deep in there and more
importantly just because ripping flowers
back - first of all you had a paper
route yeah let's break that down for a
minute okay maybe you were scared of
asking for money just like the last kid
but let's really really talk about it
yeah the [ __ ] were you doing with a
paper route am I in my family you had to
have a job cool our parents made me get
a paper route do they make you get a
paper route or did you have more than
one choice Tom now this is very
important I don't remember fair enough I
don't I believe to me well here let's
answer that question so let's assume for
a second that I'm secretly a born
entrepreneur in a bad environment I'm
very okay not a bad environment it's bad
for entrepreneurs yeah sure great
environment that I have no beef with
that so my thing is knowing that people
can either a good environment be trained
and bring out those natural inclinations
or not my thing is figure out what you
want to do and then go down the path of
gaining mastery in that in that I
apologize now being selfish because it's
so fun hanging with you fear yeah right
fear is an incredible part of all of
this yes when when and how did you start
taking fear out of the equation that's
the transition you made I don't know I
would never say that I winter-like fear
for me as a monster you feared
asking people for money definitively
cool later you didn't know I still do
interesting me too by the way this is
the weirdest part of me one of the
reasons
didn't finish off raising my fund
because I hate asking people for money
but I don't know if I fear it I just
hate it I hate I hate anybody having
leverage that's really what I'm on yeah
I'd really have to sit down and think
about the semantics of whether I just
hate it or I fear it but there are
definitely things that I do that I fear
and I move I use fear as a guidepost of
where to move because my fundamental
assumption is humans adapt via stress so
your restrictions are and and an
adversity are such an incredible frame
right and those are the things oh by the
way the biggest reason I want to talk
about real and fake entrepreneurs right
now you know why there's no [ __ ]
restrictions to being an entrepreneur
not only in money but in the bio of your
[ __ ] Instagram account right this is
it this is the punchline unlike you know
you and I are so [ __ ] similar like I
have so much fun with it because that
means I love you so much cuz [ __ ] I love
myself no but I'm serious
by the way self-love is soup like the
greatest gift by the way loving yourself
doesn't mean you're delusional and think
you're great like self-awareness is the
foundation of loving yourself I love
myself for the things that I am and I'm
not a super important like how come come
in the same way that people were
uncomfortable talking about mental
health we need to start making it
comfortable for people who like
themselves to talk about it because it
will encourage other people to realize
legging yourself is an ego or delusion
it's grounded in self-awareness yeah
here's the thing you your super powers
you don't judge yourself you're right
that became very clear to me and I know
that's amazing by the way you nail and
you know what else not judging yourself
does you don't judge other people either
so you end up liking a lot more people
you [ __ ] are judging last night
I spent ninety eight hours consuming
judgment hmm people [ __ ] jet we're
doing this post election people judge
who the [ __ ] you have no context of
what's going on in somebody's bedroom or
mostly important in their head you're
right I don't judge myself because I
know what my intent is I mean I'm
obsessed with intent it's insane how
much I love everybody here if I know
their intent once I once I wrap my head
around one's intent it's game over
like [ __ ] binary switch and I'm going
to bat for them in perpetuity for me
outside of me with me against me if I
think somebody is a good person and they
literally my door a competitor i weirdly
secretly root for them in some weird way
because if they're better than me they
deserve to win yeah I was so pumped when
I was with all those super angels and
Scott Belsky and Chris Sacca had better
invest in me I had a great investing
career they were better and I loved
talking about it right talking about
they deserve it
so what love about sports man none of
this [ __ ] of like our entrepreneur
entrepreneurships amazing you know why
nobody can judge it it's all hidden mmm
man doing god do I want the world built
you know why people are confused
everybody thinks I want the world to
melt because I do a bad job
communicating because I like keeping a
lot of [ __ ] in that I'm gonna take
advantage of it I want the world to melt
because people are gonna be happier
that's really interesting calm people
are in fake environments no listen this
is my time smart man he gets it he gets
it right away
I'm serious people can be happier
because everybody's living a fake life
right now and keeping up with the
Joneses and when everything melts
everybody gets back to the right not
paying the piper in 2009 in America for
the economic melting and going through
seven years of a recession and us
propping up [ __ ] our culture in a way
that nobody talks about
have you read the stand by Stephen King
I don't of course I already knew the
answer so here we go yeah because it
literally speaks for exactly this this
the center character of the book is
somebody who's just popping off as a
musician right when this world ending
flu happens but the guy survives and so
he goes from everybody loves me they're
treating it as well I've got free
cocaine and then now no one knows who
the [ __ ] I am and a whole machinery that
was about to make me like the biggest
thing in the planet just fell out from
under him and he's so low and what's not
so low because there's you know enough
people to survive but he realizes like
all that [ __ ] that he was chasing
now that just doesn't exist
so there's like the simplification of
life and to your point as he gets beyond
that hunger for the fame and the
adulation and just has to deal with
staying alive like his life actually
gets better I love this [ __ ] so
God can I not wait for the economic
meltdown because it's the beginning of
happiness at a bigger scale it's
interesting so the the comic book that
we wrote for neon future is literally
about that so I wanted to start post
economic meltdown look at how people
react then then super you're better look
like me right we'll have to work that in
Gary we'll have to work that in Caesar
starts wrong you'll be answering my
man's question yeah yeah no yeah for
sure um I didn't I didn't have one other
question that's just been like on me for
about a month or so so I said some hang
up that's nothing long I'm concerned god
fast you know I'm busy you know I guess
well in the dirt I guess you could say I
just graduated from college and I'm
working for actually a start-up here in
Cincinnati and the sale has big
development and you know being around
this environment you know I'm listening
to you Gary and and Tom I truly believe
I've had a lot of entrepreneurial
tendencies so you know I'm building my
personal brand and you know just very I
guess documenting the things that I
believe in things that I'm learning
throughout life just through LinkedIn
and blogging so you're either
documenting more than postering right
yeah no I'm not faking it I you know
some people know if I don't know
something so I'm in the dirt but I know
you also say to try as many things as
possible in your age pieces maybe
remember and this is what heart is hard
about advice and putting out content
people start blending in that's why I
have a lot of empathy for your patients
thing when kids ask me I have no idea
what I want to do Gary I don't know what
I like the only practical answer to that
is like yo bro hey gal go taste some
[ __ ] it sounds like you have a better
feel of what you like and thus you don't
have to quit this startup and be a
sous-chef
right no I guess I get and then like my
fault I don't question that is you know
I in doing this I have a lot of people
ask me why are you doing this what do
you do it you're like what are you
trying to get out of the or where you
see or what are you trying to be in 30
in 10 years or tell them to go [ __ ]
themselves who gives a [ __ ] you don't
know feels [ __ ] no asked brother the
next time somebody says were you gonna
be at 30 or where do you see yourselves
in five years or 10 years
look I'm dead in the face and say what
about you you don't even miss araba
[ __ ] fifty four year olds there are
most and I'll give you a slightly
different take on that and I'll say that
that skills have utility man this is
something that people don't think about
like you're gonna spend years developing
a skill set that skill set is going to
let you do something and so what do you
want to be able to do and that's the
thing to me about adaptation about
anybody being an entrepreneur or not
it's like it's just about skill
acquisition the difference between where
I was when I didn't know what the [ __ ] I
was doing as an entrepreneur and now
when I do is I've learned a set of
skills that apply themselves in the real
world either influencing other people
getting them pointed in the same
direction creating momentum knowing how
to sell knowing how to market a thousand
attack howl 2,000 percent 42 and you're
young as [ __ ] as 43 March so listen boys
do you understand
absolutely no but do you like like who
gives a [ __ ] why they're asked bro
people asking questions like that it's
fascinating to me I've been really
watching this obviously like the amount
of people that asked that question
sheerly out of misery loves company has
been one of the most fascinating things
for me to observe I think people also
terrify they're gonna miss out on
something and it's the only thing that
you have is today so if you're worried
about today and you take care of today
ten years from now is gonna take care of
itself
you're also [ __ ] love doing right now
what do you want to get great after
right now you're so right
because you're not gonna know the
alternative there's no weird video game
where you pick a path but then you get
to rewind it and watch what would have
happened like if you go star go to move
to the company's head
in Afghanistan or go to work to a
different friend in Cincinnati or move
to the big city of New York Royce you're
not gonna know how it would have worked
out and if it sucks switch it up like
that's the thing that drives me nuts
here's how I think entrepreneurs need to
think of themselves you're standing in a
room with a thousand doors your job is
to close 999 of them and walk through
one people are so paralyzed by all the
opportunity cost of actually having to
shut a door that they never make a
decision make a decision even if it's
[ __ ] terrible dude mistakes are the
most information rich data stream there
is the standing still is the only
problem I make decisions so fast it
scares the [ __ ] out of everybody around
me yeah seriously
I'm just making decisions like the end
yep and that my friend is why you win
you can add value to the show here's the
thing even if you didn't it's better to
have a decision and be able to go try
this is there in [ __ ] time and the I
love losing this is how it all works
together I'm welcome I made the wrong
decision I'm not gonna do that decision
in that circumstance if I recognize it
again right yeah I think of
entrepreneurs as athletes that don't
have a limit to their body so it's like
it's one thing if you know you're only
gonna be in the NFL for four years
because your body can't take the tax
when you're gonna be in it forever it's
like yeah if you [ __ ] this play up you
make a mistake with more science than
people realize like you're learning from
the nose it's a data point you build on
top of it for sure I'm insanely better
than I was at 22 which would blow the 22
year old man out of the water because I
thought it was the best then experience
[ __ ] matters for sure and what the 22
year old named Royce doesn't know is
that 42 year old Tom feels exactly the
way Royce does right this second because
when you're doing what you love and
you're in that zone I feel way younger
than 99% of the 22 year olds that are
unhappy that is for sure
[ __ ] Truman and just flirty level
like that's a thing and I know you get a
lot of criticism for it I get a lot
criticism for how many hours I work and
I'm like [ __ ] are you not
listening like here's the punchline
happy I work that hard because I'm
having fun happy I don't want to go
skiing
[ __ ] I do not want to go skiing I do
not want to go to a beer garden it is
not fun for me to go look at a museum I
am NOT interested in watching Netflix I
am NOT interested that doesn't mean that
I think everybody else should do that I
think and I've said consistently
self-awareness happiness I've said it a
million [ __ ] times do I believe in
hustle yes I do I like work ethic it's
controllable do I want that to put you
into depression or health scares yeah of
course not dick face of course not but
don't sit on a pedestal after you
[ __ ] worked hard for 15 years and
then tell all these kids that they
should have work-life balance
you [ __ ] elitist and dude I'm yeah if
that's not be a [ __ ] hypocrite do not
be a hypocrite if you make forty seven
thousand I only talked what I live right
just like it's why I'm just really
scared when you're like when you
transition on that one debate we're
having a little bit there and you're
like weird because I just live the
actual opposite like [ __ ] because it's a
number one thing I believe in I hate
when people work 11 years on their
startup work their faces off
I watched them grind and then they hit
and then they're sitting on money and
they're not part of their life and then
the advice they're giving isn't what
they live
I want to hear four people publicly that
made 47 thousand a year their whole life
and are happy as [ __ ] goes talk about
that we're talking about happiness
people are using mental health as a
weapon to make themselves look good just
like nonprofits you might be tricking
the 99% but you're not tricking the 1%
partner
cool thanks Royce was amazing man Tommy
get to ask the question of the day
there's only one at least from my
perspective what is the impact you want
to have on the world
cuz baby chasing fulfillment that's the
game the [ __ ] ROI
thank you brother you gotta thank you
you keep asking questions we'll keep
answering them
book Tom for speaking
[Music]